بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى في
كتابه رياض الصالحين في باب الصبر منه في
الحديث الثالث بعد الاربعين
وعن انس رضي الله عنه قال قال رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اذا اراد الله بعبده خيرا عجل له العقوبه
في الدنيا
واذا اراد الله بعبده الشر
امسك عنه بذنبه حتى يوافي به يوم القيامه
الرياض الصالحين
الحافظ النووي
انس رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏willen to him
punishment in the for any sin
accumulated
and if desires for a servant of
bad
he will refrain from hastening
[Silence]
هنا
يصف النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله عز وجل
بانه يريد
لبعض عباده هذه الخيره
ويريد
ببعض عباده الشره
من يريد بهم الخير
الذين اصطفاهم وطهر قلوبهم
و
ارادهم لنفسه
ومن يريد
من عباده بالشر
الذين
يقترفون
الاثام
ولم يصطفيهم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
والذين يمكرون السيئات
ويمكرون
بعباد الله الصالحين
يقول الله تعالى في الحديث القدسي من عاد
لي وليا
فقد اذنته بالحرب
الله سبحانه وتالى
desires other
desires
for those chosen
he desires for those
earn
anger
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز
ومن يحلل عليه غضبي
اذا يحل غضب الله
على
بعض عباده بحق
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏angn
by
a portion of slaves of servant
those who are not born into the anger of
Allah
they do not receive the anger of Allah
because
of a sin that was someone's
no
that is a
‏and go out
ang
الله سبحانه وى
unn
يقول الله تعالى
وما كنا معذبين
حتى نبعث رسولا
‏ang
ander
that knowc
of free will andc the gra
ang
however wear
الله سبحانه وى
‏and
why not because
in the here but also because
it is to
[Silence]
وقال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يعني هذا
ايضا من حديث انس عند الترمذي
ان عظم الجزاء مع عظم البلاء
وان الله تعالى اذا احب قوما ابتلاهم
فمن رضي
اي من عباده بما قضى الله
وبلاء الله فله الرضا اي من الله
ومن سخط فله السخط
صلى الله عليه
‏and الله if people will
try them
will them of the gift the gift of
difficulty
that a person can to
الله
رضي الله عنهم
البلاء
الحافظ البخاري
الادب المفرد
كانوا يفرحون
بالبلاء
كما يفرح احدكم بالدينار والدرهم
‏that they would
be excited and they would be
el with the difficulty that comes their
way as
anage person would be happy with
receiving
gold and silver why because this means
that they are being given either
expiation
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏are inuting
from
heed
great reward comes
‏anded the ifoves people willbulate
them will give them tribulation hardship
not hardship to break them hardship to
make them better
and in order to teach them and in order
to expiate them and raise their levels
hence whoever is pleased with what Allah
has chosen for him for him is pleasure
andever
الله
الحافظ الترمذي رحمه الله وقال حديث حسن
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يبتلينا بلاء
حسنا وانلا يحملنا ما لا طاقه لنا به
نساله سبحانه ان يعفو عنا وان يغفر لنا
وان يرحمنا وان يكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وان يقينا عذاب النار وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين